there have been many tributes around the
world to Queen Elizabeth including in
Paris look at that the lights they were
turned off at the iconic Eiffel Tower as
a show of respect to her while here in
this country the Empire State Building
lit up in royal colors that's purple and
silver earlier in the day the bells at
the Washington's National Cathedral told
96 times one for each year of the
Queen's life and then the flags they
were lowered to half staff as well in
the nation's capital and all around the
country you know the Queen's connection
to the U.S goes back further than many
can remember since her rain began before
most of us were born there were 14
presidents during the Queen Elizabeth's
Reign and she met all but one from Harry
Truman all the way up to President Biden
when he visited the UK just last year
our Nancy Cordes is at the white house
right now with more on a leader who was
part of multiple generations of American
History Nancy good morning
good morning Eureka yes if you think
about it there are few people in history
if any who knew as many U.S presidents
as she did she hosted them they hosted
her there were dances and horseback
rides and a baseball game all of it
emblematic of that special relationship
between her country and Ours
long before Camelot came to London or
President Reagan rode horseback with the
Queen and Princess Elizabeth makes her
first appearance in the states yes then
princess Elizabeth met her first
American President Harry Truman more
than 70 years ago in Washington very
great pleasure for me as the President
of the United States uh to welcome you
to the capital of our country she came
back as Queen later that decade and met
Dwight Eisenhower later sending him her
recipe for scones Her Majesty hosted a
dinner for John F Kennedy and his wife
Jackie at Buckingham Palace then one for
Richard Nixon who once tried to set up
his daughter Trisha with Prince Charles
that transatlantic Alliance didn't take
the queen took Gerald Ford's hand as a
dance partner in 1976 to celebrate the
bicentennial of American independence
from the British throne a milestone that
three decades later tripped up another
president you helped our nation
celebrate its Bicentennial in 17 and
1976.
[Music]
she gave me a look that only a mother
could give a child perhaps no president
got the relationship right more than
Ronald Reagan who stayed and played with
the queen at Windsor Castle the pair
also shared laughs in California where
her majesty hosted the Reagans aboard
her royal yacht
the queen seemed just as home taking in
America's pastime at a baseball game in
Baltimore with George H.W bush in 1991.
Mr Speaker then the next day in D.C
uniting both parties after the Gulf War
we have both learned from history but we
must not allow aggression to succeed
there have been some presidential
missteps like when Mr Trump stepped in
front of the queen there were times the
special relationship got a little too
close like this distinctly British
Embrace with First Lady Michelle Obama
to her majesty the queen
for the Vitality of the special
relationship or or when Mr Obama kept
talking that Royal mistake as the band
began to play the British national
anthem to the queen
but throughout it all the respect for
this legendary Monarch was always
evident but talk we will
listen we have to
disagree from time to time we may
but united we must always remain
the first time President Biden met the
queen was 40 years ago in 1982 when he
was still a U.S senator and the last
time he saw her was last year at Windsor
Castle when he said that she reminded
him of his mom last night he signed a
condolence book at the UK Embassy here
in Washington and said that he is likely
to attend the Royal Funeral in the days
to come drinka
Nancy cord is for us at the White House
thank you so much